all right so here's a little bit of what
I've been working on illustrating so as
you can see here people log in with
their gmail account and then the step
two is we visualize their network data
so here is again this is a very this is
a two-dimensional so this is not 3d
quite yet we're aiming to visualize how
it would populate in 3d and whatnot but
right now there's a specialist edge of
knowledge and there is a most
generalists in the center so the general
star in the center and the specialist
edge of knowledge across all these blue
fields let's just hypothetically say
then the green nodes that you see in the
circle are your recent email completed
with this note so that's why they're
green
but these red more red nodes are the
nodes that you have it's been a long
time since you've had a recent email
with this node then you can see that the
size of the node is size of node equals
connection strength to you so Matt is a
big node so he's a bigger connection
whereas these little tiny nodes over
here and over there and whatnot less
strong of a connection to me but here's
what's interesting is that you can also
see how these red bars these kind of
bonds right bars or bonds if you have a
single ball bar or a bond with two nodes
this is their connection strength to
each other so our connection strength to
the node is by their size but the
connection strength of them to each
other is by these bars or these bonds so
here's Kim is connected to this question
mark this question works closer to some
of the neuroscience area and Kim's got a
quad bond for so it's strong bond
between the notes and then if you follow
this question mark out you see that this
is where the machine learning model
prompts me with new nodes as a daily
suggestions showing me nodes I already
know well who can yes to know the intro
after I say I'm interested so meaning
this node is a request as a male models
predicting I should connect to it and
then it's also showing that Kim's got a
quad bond to it so
then it's like do you want to connect
yes or no and then the question would be
just Kim get prompted and then select
yes or no to introduce Alan to this
question mark node and so this is kind
of about like the consent question and
stuff or should this ml model just
predate that Kim should be connecting
this note to Alan and then have that be
one of her options and that's this
option mo model prompts me with five
daily suggestions to connect nodes in my
network so this would be what Kim would
get Kim would get one of these you know
there's these question mark nodes right
and these question mark nodes would be
the ones that for example Kim would be
getting this this daily suggestion to
connect me to this node and so she'd get
this five daily suggestions both with
high confidence and some low confidence
because on the low confidence there's
going to be creativity creative options
so we can see maybe this twenty or
thirty percent confidence connection is
actually one that Alan wants and this is
kind of the creativity of the mo model
just like we saw the creativity and some
of of alphago with playing these new
moves in chess and jeopardy and alpha
star etc that they're playing new moves
they're playing some moves that actually
have a significant creative edge and so
this can be something similar that we
learn from that process and then likely
lastly to explain here is just that it's
also interesting to see down here that
the ml model can also prompt these
loving check in the emails to read notes
so like Kim to turn them green so I can
check in with the close friend after six
months of cetera so we can automate a
prompt that sense to me you know do you
want to check in with Kim it's been six
months she's read on your on your note
you can turn her green and so you can
better keep in touch with people this
way you can better not only connect to
the prominent nodes that are that that
you can connect to but also connect your
friends to prominent nodes that other
nodes that can help them with their
goals so this has been just a little bit
of some of the visualization and the
thoughts on my mind around this project
I'm extremely extremely grateful to be
working on this it's SuperDuper fun and
it's just such a blessing because I love
network theory I love mathematical
sociology
love cybernetics and I love being able
to accelerate people's dreams being
executed faster by connecting powerful
people I want that to be automated more
effectively and I want us to be able to
find our hot 50 all of these notes find
your hot 50 faster and connect yourself
to the important folks and just have our
data be better working for us
much love Matt much love Joshua you guys
are exciting and I hope we can you know
build this out and get people working
with this so just some initial thoughts
and let's uh let's execute make it
happen version 2 will start popping in
the LinkedIn Twitter Instagram Facebook
as much data as we tend into to really
synthesize the data and bunch of other
cool stuff aversion to anyway this is
some of the things that we're now
thinking about I think we can obviously
charge people like 30 bucks a month for
this service once they see that they're
gaining tremendous value from it people
can totally afford it people pay 30
bucks a month for superhuman and things
of high value so we can do this and we
can scale this and we can look back at
this one day and laugh because this is
some of the earliest days of building
out one of the most important projects
of providing other people with value
around the world and connecting people
like we want to be able to query this
graph for Neuroscience we want to query
it for Hong Kong we want to query it for
generalists as well all this cool stuff
that we can query these graphs for all
right much loved thanks